[Music]
on this wednesday night the push to
fully vaccinate vulnerable canadians
sooner they're particular sitting ducks
right now
how some provinces are speeding up plans
to give out the second dose
europe's plan to open its borders to the
fully vaccinated
thank you to the portuguese government
the vaccine what it could mean for
canadian travelers
doctors orders the multiplying calls to
call off the tokyo olympics
and i call it a cicada palooza they're
back
they're gonna fly to the treetops in the
big romantic party in the sky
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with a question that's emerging
as more and more canadians get a first
dose of covid19 vaccine
when will they get the second shot and
will the four-month interval between
doses be shortened at this point 17.8
million canadians or 47 percent of those
eligible have had at least one dose
only about 1.4 million people though 3.9
percent
have been fully vaccinated with both
shots the provinces had agreed to extend
the interval between doses to
16 weeks to get more people a first dose
as fast as possible
now with millions more doses arriving
some provinces are
accelerating plans to get people fully
vaccinated
today we're announcing that the booking
of second doses will launch
this friday for individuals with
specific health
conditions
there is a lot to look forward to once
second doses are rolled out and that's
especially true for canada's
elderly michael couture has our top
story tonight
i've done everything on this truck
myself 81 year old russell downey has
been spending a lot more time
tinkering with his old truck with just
one dose of the covet 19 vaccine
he limits how much he runs errands and
his granddaughter
prefers it that way it's very very
frightening
every time i hear him going to get
groceries
because i have to think of where did you
go how many people have you interacted
with
russell isn't as worried i'm wearing
gloves and
masks and i disinfect my hands as soon
as i come out of the grocery store i
have a bottle in my car
all the time they're particularly
sitting ducks right now
for getting cobit 19 and dying while
most canadians living in long-term care
homes have been fully vaccinated
dr samir sinha says there are close to
nine million elderly canadians
who live independently and aren't fully
protected
people you know who are 80 and older the
ones who have the greatest risk of dying
we know that they don't mount as good of
a immune response to that first dose
statistics show less than 20 percent of
that age group
have two dose immunity among canadians
60 years and older
less than 7 percent have received both
doses
elderly manitobans will be able to book
their second doses before younger ones
manitoba is focusing on high-risk groups
with second doses while saskatchewan
is shortening the interval between doses
from 16 to 13 weeks
other provinces could follow suit some
doctors believe we can hand out more
first doses
while also reaching vulnerable
populations with second doses
there's individual protection population
level protection
we can find that sweet spot where that
venn diagram overlaps
and because we actually have so much
vaccine coming into the country
and we can likely vaccinate both shannon
downey hopes he's right and until he
gets his second dose
she wants her grandfather to stay safe
by staying home
michael couture global news ottawa
as provinces work on rollout plans for
second doses there's some new
flexibility about storing the pfizer
biantech vaccine
health canada now says it can be stored
at regular fridge temperature
at the point of use for up to one month
the previous rule was five days
pfizer had submitted a request to change
the storage restrictions because it's
been collecting longer term data about
the vaccines
stability well vaccines are key to
relaxing public health restrictions and
opening the door to the possibility
of going on vacation the european union
said today it is ready to open up to
fully vaccinated visitors the plan still
needs final approval
details are still being worked out
though some countries have already said
they won't require quarantines or
testing if
travelers are fully vaccinated french
citizens got back to sipping coffee and
wine at cafes and restaurants
for the first time in six months
non-essential retail shops were also
reopened customers turned out in droves
they also lined up to be the first
inside museums like
the louvre could that be us abigail
beeman looks at
what the eu's plans might mean for
canadians
iconic beer gardens and viennese coffee
houses
austria is one of the latest european
countries closer to a normal summer
cheers thank you to the portuguese
government on the whole
eu nations agreed to expand the list of
safe countries allowed to visit them
this will help progressively resuming
international
inbound travel where it's possible to do
so safely
while the details are being ironed out
canada is not likely to make that safe
list
it will require countries to have fewer
than 75 cases per 100 000 people
in the last 14 days canada currently
sits
at 232 cases but
canadians could still have a european
vacation
if you've had both doses of the vaccine
at least 14 days before you travel
we are very likely going to be able to
travel
abroad depends where the question is not
can we but should be dr christopher labo
says people should avoid parts of the
world with high covet rates
elsewhere for those vaccinated he says
the risk is very low
but not zero so be careful to avoid
ending up sick in a foreign hospital
across canada summer vacation may be a
safer bet
i think the most likely explanation is
that by
july august case counts will have
decreased far enough that most provinces
will not have travel restrictions and as
far as our neighbors to the south so far
no changes to visiting the u.s
and vice versa no matter your
vaccination status
we'll see what framework we apply to
ensure that we're keeping canadians safe
even as we look to eventually
changing the restrictions and the
posture at the border
and no matter your international
vacation destination
when you return home you still need to
quarantine for two weeks
with up to three days in a government
approved hotel if you've arrived by
air at this point the government has
nothing new to say about when those
restrictions
will lift abigail beeman global news
ottawa
there is no relief from restrictions yet
for people in nova scotia that province
has extended its shutdown
until at least the second week of june
students will not be back in classrooms
before the end of the school year
the new case numbers continue to be too
high and the number of people in the
hospital
continues also to be challenging we need
to get our case numbers
much further down before we can begin
slowly reopening
83 new infections were reported in nova
scotia today and two more people
have died japan is battling a spike in
cases that threatens to overwhelm
hospitals there just weeks before 15 000
athletes arrive for the summer olympics
japan's problem is not unique many asian
countries are dealing with dangerous
outbreaks
after appearing to have the virus under
control and as eric sorenson reports
they also share a troubling trend
in vaccinations they were the success
stories
taiwan kept covered out almost
completely but new variants have slipped
in and spread
hong kong and singapore have postponed a
quarantine free travel bubble
and thailand is rushing to vaccinate
after more covet deaths in the last
three days than in all of last year
and then there is japan which confronts
a unique predicament
covid case numbers have jumped to the
highest levels in four months
as tokyo stages events preparing for the
olympics
in just nine weeks already reduced in
scale the games are increasingly
unwelcome in japan
thousands signed an online petition to
cancel them a major medical association
says there aren't enough doctors and
nurses
to spare for the olympics i believe it
is impossible to hold the olympics
safely says this top doctor
japan is a victim of its own success it
didn't need vaccines at first
and now less than four percent have
received shots
the athletes will increase the infection
risk says this protester
the ioc is desperately trying to
reassure the host country
this full commitment of the ioc
to organize together save olympic
and paralympic games for everybody
canadian wrestler erica weave is
training
still hoping the games go ahead to stay
mentally and physically healthy
it's been an unprecedented challenge for
canadian athletes like myself
but others question the wisdom of
staging the olympics during a global
pandemic
get a whole bunch of people from all
over the world to travel to one place
mix and close quarters and then go back
again that's a recipe for making things
worse
a former canadian rowing silver medalist
says ultimately it should be up to the
japanese
if the people that are at the greatest
risks for these games
feel that they should not go forward
then they should not go
forward a new poll finds more than 80
percent of japanese don't want the
olympics to go forward
eric sorensen global news toronto
95 athletes from india have qualified
for the tokyo games but training is
being hampered by lockdowns
and travel restrictions india reported
over 4 500 deaths from kobit 19 today
that is more than any other country in a
single day at any time during the
pandemic
new infections are also spreading
rapidly india confirmed over 267
thousand cases today alone
there's talk of a possible ceasefire at
some point between israel and hamas but
tonight
there's no sign of it the u.s president
joe biden has called the israeli prime
minister again
this time saying he expects a
significant de-escalation in violence on
the path
to a ceasefire benjamin netanyahu says
he's determined to carry on with the
attacks until israel's aim
is met for a tenth day israel kept
targeting gaza and hamas
kept up rocket attacks on israel most
were intercepted by israel's iron dome
defense system
israel's medical service says 12
israelis have been killed now including
two children
the toll in gaza is almost 20 times that
gaza's health ministry says at least 227
people have been killed including
more than 100 women and children redmond
shannon reports
a phone call from israeli intelligence
warning residents of a gaza street
to clear the area
moments later an airstrike hits another
building
obliterated damage across the
neighborhood
no deaths here but at least nine more
gazans were killed wednesday
israel says it's killed more than 150
militants
since may 10 but doesn't detail the
innocent people who've died
there is no army in the world that does
more than the israeli army
in israeli security services and israeli
intelligence
to prevent collateral damage benjamin
netanyahu's
walk and talk news conference made no
mention of rumored ceasefires
instead he stressed israel's efforts to
play by the rules
there are probably children there so
we're not going to do it
gazan authorities say more than 60
children have been killed since may 10th
the ngo the norwegian refugee council
says
11 of the gazan children it's been
treating for
psychological trauma have died in air
strikes
u.s president joe biden spoke with
netanyahu again
saying the united states expected a
significant de-escalation wednesday
on the path to a ceasefire
shortly afterwards netanyahu who is
currently clinging on to his job in a
hung parliament
said he is determined to continue until
peace in israel is restored
in other words as long as rockets from
gaza have israelis running for cover
israel will keep firing back redmond
shannon double news
london new calls for justice
coming up the canadian professor being
ordered to stand trial again
in france
there is an update tonight on the
military investigation into the former
head of canada's vaccine rollout major
general danny forte
canada's military police now say they've
referred their investigation
into an allegation of sexual misconduct
to quebec's prosecution service it's now
up to the prosecutor's office to decide
whether charges are
warranted fortan left his role with a
vaccine task force last friday
after it emerged he was under
investigation forte
denies the allegation the fate of an
ottawa professor is in question again
tonight a french court has upheld a
decision ordering hassan diab
be tried in the 1980 bombing of a paris
synagogue
as david aiken explains it's unclear
whether or not canada will be asked to
extradite him
a second time stark moments
hassan diab had already been extradited
from canada to france once
back in 2014 even though france
never charged him with any crime and yet
he spent
three years in a maximum-security french
prison
much of it in solitary confinement until
in 2018
a french court released diab ruling
there was not enough evidence to charge
him
that's pretty shocking i think and
should be troubling for any canadian
to know that the the bar in our
own laws is so low uh that
any nation that shows up with with
practically no evidence at
all can nonetheless seek our extradition
and succeed
now france's highest court overturned
that 2018 ruling
clearing the way for a new trial date
diab now 67
and his wife cannot believe it the
family
is devastated and they
understand that there is no evidence
and the courts have failed to deliver
justice at every single turn through two
levels of court in canada through
three levels of court now in france and
there comes a point where enough
is enough i think for uh assange we have
to
recognize first of all that what
happened to him never should have
happened that was prime minister justin
trudeau
three years ago asked two months ago if
he would protect dia from any future
extradition
trudeau was more circumspect we have
continued to engage
with officials in france on this case
and we will continue too trudeau wasn't
speaking to reporters today but his
justice minister david lametty released
a statement and he said
because the matter is before the courts
no comment
donna all right david aiken in ottawa
thanks
still ahead the nurses putting their
lives on hold to help ontario
through its third wave
a team of nurses from across canada is
helping exhausted colleagues
in toronto hospitals thanks to the
canadian red cross nurses from alberta
bc quebec ontario and the northwest
territories
have flown to toronto to lend a hand in
three hospitals
karen lieberman went to one icu to find
out what difference
they're making so every day i've been
here
nurses have taken on double patient
loads the patients just
need a lot they're very sick and there's
a lot of them
i see you as exhausting as it is covered
pandemic it's just like
tenfold that's why brita jensen is here
in toronto
from her native vancouver deployed by
the canadian red cross to help
so i've been an icu nurse for eight
years now i've worked
three shifts here i feel like i've been
working for a month
when the pandemic started jensen was
home on maternity leave but felt
compelled to help her nursing colleagues
so she reached out to the red cross i
was working in long-term care homes
helping provide
public health support to them i worked
in federal prisons for a little bit
and then worked at the border doing
testing for
a few weeks and then the call came that
they needed nurses that could do icu
support
a major concern throughout the third
wave of the pandemic
has been the pressure on intensive care
units and a shortage of skilled nurses
to help care for the rising critical
caseload
i applied essentially thinking i was
doing vaccinations
because i've i just worked for doctors
of borders and i did a lot of
vaccination campaigns
instead longtime trauma nurse nicole
desi was also deployed here
to humber river hospital so for me it's
more
just like how busy it is like
how sick the patients are how young the
patients are
the amount of resuscitations that i've
seen here
21 years working in icus and this nurse
was on the verge of retirement
but those plans were put on hold i need
to help my colleagues
and even help the public she worked the
front lines during the sars outbreak and
h1n1 pandemic
but kovid19 is unlike anything she has
seen before
it's very sad
being a situation like that
i'll go into the end to help by going to
the end
a team of nurses providing relief in a
time of need
karen lieberman global news toronto
this year's cicada palooza next a taste
of an explosive bug event
you've no doubt heard by now about the
explosion of cicadas in parts of the
united states
and when i say explosion i am not
exaggerating
there are trillions of the very loud
wind winged
insects and for some reason our
washington bureau chief jackson proskow
volunteered to go and see them for
himself
apologies if some of the images give you
the heebie-jeebies
they said there would be cicadas they
weren't kidding we knew that it was
millions but sometimes millions just
sound like
like a little bit too much right but
then you actually see them and it's like
okay yeah yeah there are millions
this is my super bowl this is what i
look forward to
every 17 years entomologist mike ropp
took us on a tour of cicada country
where right on cue they've come crawling
out of the ground
we can still see some of the nymphs
emerging
they shed their exoskeletons and make
their way up the trees
looking for love and that's where they
sing millions of male cicadas
in chorus hoping to attract that special
someone
they're going to fly to the treetops to
join their broodmates
in the big romantic party in the sky
i call it a cicada palooza after laying
eggs that drop
back into the ground the adults die off
their sheer numbers are all about
survival of the species
that's their whole life to be a clumsy
bug with lots of them out there
to overall predators and still leave
millions around
to survive and reproduce that's just
that's just so cool
today's cicadas have been underground
since 2004.
they missed the arrival of iphones and
facebook yet their plight feels more
relatable than ever
they've been social distancing for 17
years so now they're coming up and out
you know they're meeting their other
fellows they're meeting the other
members of their species just like us
and like any good reunion their rare
arrival calls for a special meal
one where cicadas are the main
ingredient chefs are buzzing about the
chance to whip up a cicada stir fry or
cicada pizza
and don't forget dessert these are the
cicada cookies
slow roasted is apparently the preferred
cooking method uh let's see how this
goes
jackson frost go global news hmm
it's kind of crunchy colombia maryland
can't watch that that is global national
for this wednesday
tonight's your canada starts with an
apology to the mayor of toronto
i'm sorry we don't want to pile on but
john tory's hair is a sign of the times
it's what happens when hair salons have
been closed since december
some say it looks regal others say it's
reminiscent of beethoven
and people want to help
is this a samson situation will he lose
his strength to be mayor of canada's
most populous city if his hair is cut
we don't care somebody just needs to
give that man a haircut
do your part to help and the lockdown by
getting vaccinated and wearing a mask
when you need to
torrey responded thanks whatever it
takes to get people vaccinated
he's a good sport take care of
yourselves bye-bye
you